hey folks i don't do this often but i
need to make a direct appeal to you
today today is black friday and that
means we need your membership okay we
just do
right now we have the best deal of the
year it's 50 off four new members at
dw50 again that's code dw50 when you
click the link here and you use code
dw50 to get 50 off all new memberships
but here's the thing it's not just you
get all the great content you know the
extra stuff with me hanging out with me
as an all access member for example or
watching canvas's show or becoming part
of the sweet baby gang with matt walsh
it's that you make a difference with
your help we've made so much of a
difference this year we need your help
to do it okay between last thanksgiving
and this thanksgiving let me just give
you a taste of what you have helped us
do here at daily wire first you allowed
us to help gina carano so gina was fired
from disney plus for no good reason at
all simply because they didn't like her
political point of view we picked her up
we're making a movie it's coming out
next year it's going to be fantastic
terror on the prairie we're jumping into
that entertainment space with your help
we have a bunch of entertainment stuff
coming down the pike including the brand
new adam corello series truth yeller
which is available right now also
just as importantly maybe more
importantly you allowed us to jump in
and fight the fight with regard to
investigative journalism so our
investigative reporter luke roziak you
remember he is the guy who broke wide
open the loudoun county story in which a
parent who had basically been treated as
domestic terrorists by the media and
also by the government it turns out that
the reason that he was so upset at the
school board is because they were
overtly lying about the fact that his
daughter had been attacked in a bathroom
stall and they were doing that in order
to promote transgenderism and
transgender bathrooms we fought back
against the radical trans movement and
made a huge difference in loudoun county
and now the governor of virginia the
incoming governor is going to be a
republican glenn young that's because of
our investigative reporting and that's
because of your help and then just as
big you are helping us fight the biden
administration vaccine mandate all
across the country 100 million people
are going to be forced to vax or be
fired unless we stop them and we have
taken the lyric lead here at daily wire
we here at daily wire said day one we
are not going to comply with joe biden's
unconstitutional and tyrannical vast
mandate we could do that because we had
the confidence of having you behind us
because of all of our members you should
become a member today and help us out as
we take joe biden all the way to the
supreme court and stop that vax mandate
right now that case is at the sixth
circuit court of appeals we are the
leading plaintiffs against osha against
the bite administration in that case you
make all of that possible your
membership and we need your help today
it's the biggest shopping day of the
year so while you're getting gifts for
yourself gifts for friends and family
for christmas make sure that you stop by
dailywire.com use code dw50 use the link
here code dw50 for 50 off you can help
us not just get all the great content
that you'll get by becoming a member
not just hanging out with me or with
candace or michael knowles with matt
walsh with andrew clavin not just
hanging out with us at backstage and all
the perks of the brand new merch store
we have all sorts of great merch you get
a discount when you are a member but
most importantly you're fighting the
fight when you join with us and become a
member you are part of the army that is
fighting on behalf of conservative
ideals which means fighting on behalf of
the declaration of independence the
constitution of the united states and
fundamental judeo-christian
notions of right and wrong as well as
liberty and freedom so we need your help
once more code dw50 for 50 off we really
appreciate all you do you make all of
this possible keep making it possible
become a member today code dw50 for 50
off on black friday